the average person uh who doesn't really
think about politics much, they're busy
with their lives, their families, their
work, you know, all these things, then
yeah, China actually might be a great
place to live. If you don't care about
government and politics, if you're just
focused on your own life, then it's
probably great. But once you turn
towards the government, I still have
family living in that part of the world,
and if I get into conversations with
them online about politics, they say,
"We have to stop the conversation right
now, and we have to, you know,
>> Yeah. Exactly.
Yeah, exactly. Um I I mean I mean I I'm
very fond of the United States. I went
to university there. Most my friends
actually American uh because I respect
the open-mindedness, the generosity, the
tolerance of of Americans. Um but I'm
seeing what's happening in America,
especially this past few days, and I'm
just horrified.
>> And I think this is a new normal. I I I
think that America is heading heading
towards a civil war. And um I don't
think there's any way out of the
situation. It's a very our predicament.
>> Well, let's get into that now. The
predictive history of where we're at
today. Um let's start with Donald Trump.
A lot of people want to compare Donald
Trump to a variety of historical figures
from FDR to Hitler. [laughter]
Um, where would you say he who is he
actually most like?
>> Well, um, Donald Trump is first of all a
unique historical figure. Um, but if I
had to, um, pick an analogy, I think he
would be most similar to Julius Caesar.
So, let's go over to some aspects of
Julius Caesar that resonates with Donald
Trump. So Julius Caesar became powerful
because he took his army into Gaul and
he enslaved the population. Um so
basically Julius Caesar conducted this
unwarranted war of imperialism against
innocent people which made himself and
his soldiers rich and it it made his uh
soldiers extremely loyal to him as well.
the petition the petition class in Rome
became extremely annoyed with Caesar and
wanted to indict him basically impeach
him and so Caesar crossed the Rubicon
and installed a milit military
dictatorship and so we're seeing a very
similar uh situation play out in the
United States as well where Trump is
creating these uh paramilitary forces
like ICE and possibly the National Guard
that are loyal only to him because only
he will support uh their brutality. Um
you what we saw in Venezuela is the rise
of Delta Force. So in the future perhaps
Delta Force will become the paternian
guard for Donald Trump. And what's
driving all this is tremendous popular
discontent where people don't feel as
though um there's any hope of a better
future. remember uh in 2020
um the Democrats told the people as long
as we get we get rid of Donald Trump
things will go back to normal and Joe
Biden came into office um inflation hit
record highs and rather than trying to
make lives better yelling in the
Treasury Department gaslighted people
and told them oh no you know we're not
really in a recession um even though
everyone knew they were in a recession
when Putin invaded Ukraine uh Biden um
imposed a sanction that boomerang
against the American economy. Um, Biden
and his people should have negotiated
for peace in Ukraine, but Biden insisted
on a full-scale war with Ukraine, which
is which has led to basically the
collapse of American empire throughout
the world. So, um, there's popul, but
the Democrats do not have any solutions.
As the midterms approach, the Democrats
could be a party of of no wars, of um
more wealth redistribution, and instead
um they have absolutely no policy ideas.
And the only thing that they promise the
people is we're not Trump, and we'll
probably impeach Trump if we get into
office.
>> So um we're we're so right now the
choice for the people is not one between
democracy and monarchy. It's really one
between monarchy and oligarchy. And
given this choice, historically people
choose to pick monarchy because the
first thing that monarchs tend to do is
they actually u cancel the debt and
something called the jubilee. Uh and and
that's that's a very common way for
kings to cement popular support. So I
imagine you know if Donald Trump were to
become king and that is certainly his
ambition and he would cancel all debts
including student debt, including
mortgages uh and this would be
tremendous relief to to the American
people. Okay. So I think Julius Caesar
is the best analogy. Um and a lot of
it's just driven by incompetence among
the ruling elite. The Democrats, the
oligarchs absolutely refuse to admit
that they've done anything wrong. They
refuse to admit that um the America has
become a corrupt oligarchy
and they um have stated any political
changes including Bernie Sanders. If
Bernie Sanders had won in 2016 or 2020
then America and the world would be a
very different place. So um so it's not
just Trump, it's also this elite that
enables Trump. Um another thing that I
will say is that what seems to driving
Trump um is his thirst for revenge
because you know for Trump the biggest
drama trauma in his life is a 2020 um
election against Joe Biden because he's
actually convinced that he won the
election. But um Joe Biden, the
Europeans, Obama conspired against him.
And um how well first of all you had the
George Floyd protest in Minnesota,
right? The Black Lives Matter protest.
Uh then you had the um CO um lockdowns.
Then you you had the um mail in ballots
that swung the election in favor of Joe
Biden at at the very last minute. So you
we can see much of what he's doing as a
revenge tour. Um so so he hates the
Europeans because he's convinced the
Europeans conspired with Obama against
him in 2020. And that's why we're seeing
um Trump being so antagonistic against
the Europeans. That's one front. Another
front is that you know why did Trump go
in and kidnap Maduro? Because I think
what will happen during the trial of
Maduro is that Maduro will tell the
people that Venezuela participated in
election fraud in 2020. He will present
evidence that um uh the election was
rigged in 2020. Um, and now what we're
seeing in Minneapolis in Minneapolis in
Minnesota is, you know, these ICE agents
going around and wreaking havoc and, you
know, how things will develop um in in
Minnesota is tremendously important
because I think that there's um a very
strong likelihood that what Trump will
do next few weeks is he will pardon
Derek Schovin
and this would set the nation on higher
if he were to do that. But it plays very
much into Trump's psychology. He's
trying to create as much havoc as
possible. He's he's really trying to
instigate a civil war with his actions.
I mean, how else can you explain the
fact that you have these ICE agents um
going going around America and besieging
average American citizens?
>> Um and remember these ICE agents, their
responsibility is to deport um illegal
immigrants. But guess what? under Obama,
you had more illegal immigrants deported
than under Trump, even though um you
have this paramilitary force called ICE
um going around and supposedly run up
running up immigrants. Um I think their
main um main job is to test out the
possib possibility of a secret secret
police in in America. Um there's talk of
there's plans to deploy the National
Guard to all 50 states this year. So it
seems as though they're trying to create
the conditions for a martial law for for
martial law. [snorts]
>> How could Trump, if he has the desire,
you say, to become king? I mean,
obviously, I don't know if America would
go for an actual king. I I don't think
we would say, okay, you're we're we're
ushering in a monarch and the Trump
family is now the monarchy. But there
would be other ways to phrase it, I
suppose, and to still have the same end
result.
Well, I mean, um, let's consider what
Julius Caesar did, right? So, what
Julius Caesar did was he created a myth
of himself as this great conquering
hero. And so, that's why we see Trump
instigate wars around the world, right?
So, Trump is went into Venezuela. He's
he's talking about bombing Mexico and
Colombia. And he's talking about over
Guinand and Canada and Cuba. Um, he's
now considering attacks against Iran.
And even though you and I are horrified
by this, at a fundamental human
psychological level, this inspires awe
and fear among the people, you know,
which is what a great king tries tries
to do. So Trump is trying to present
himself first of all, first and
foremost, as this great conquering hero
who will store who will restore the
American empire. That's number one.
Number two is that as I mentioned, he's
trying to create um uh military forces
that are loyal only to him. you know,
Peter Hexev in September, last
September, you know, he said that the
new military doctrine is the war ethos.
Um, you know, we will disregard all
rules of engagement. We will engage in
maximum lethality. So, he's really
talking to a special group of people in
the military, which is a special forces,
Delta, the Delta Force, um, the Green
Berets. Uh, these are these are people
who are most sympathetic to, uh, this
sort of rhetoric. And so um the they
will eventually become the most loyal to
Trump which will allow Trump to engage
in pocket assassinations um sabotage
infiltration which is what he needs in
order to basically um um get rid of of
his political opponents. That's number
two. Number three is civil war, right?
So um to create to create a us versus
them mentality uh one between left and
right democrats and republicans where
you're forced to pick sides and in that
in that situation many people will rally
around Trump. Um that's number three. Uh
number four is to create a national
emergency. It could be civil war but it
could but it could be economic collapse
as well. So basically from a Trump
perspective the more chaos the better
because it allows him to consolidate
power. Um then of course you have the
issue lobby. The Israel lobby is very
much interested in a war against Iran
and you know Nat Netanyahu visited Trump
um you know right before the New Year's
in Mara Lago and what happened right
afterwards well you have the kidnapping
of Maduro you have these Iran protests
um you have Trump saying that he will
defend these protesters in Iran this is
not a coincidence um this is all part of
a larger scheme to um overthrow the Iran
regime and cause collapse in Iran so
that Israel can can create the greater
Israel project. And so if Trump is able
to deliver this to um Israel, then
Israel will give Trump whatever he
wants. So you know, Mayor Mayor Edison
has promised Trump $250 million if he
were to run for a third term. Ellen Mus
has pledged $20 million for the
midterms. So the resources of the Israel
lobby cannot ever be overstated.
>> Everything you're saying, it makes me
wonder. I mean in um when Trump won his
first term and there was a lot of talk
uh about oh Trump wants to be a king,
Trump wants to do XYZ thing and there
was a lot of Trump Trump wants to you
know usher in martial law, Trump wants a
civil war, Trump wants to be a king and
and during his first term I thought wow
these people are really you know Trump
derangement syndrome. I mean they're
just they're not seeing straight. But
now with this term I got to be honest
you know I sit there and I think so
there he is almost every day proving the
Democrats right. I mean, he's proving
those who were saying this guy is out
for power. He's proving them correct
almost every single day. I mean, he's
he's sitting at the White House
salivating over somebody giving him a
Nobel Peace Prize. Like, he's so um you
know, he's just so ju just focused on
all of these strange things that are
about boosting himself. I mean, it's
just the most bizarre thing to ever see.
But it makes me wonder, you know, when
you say, look, they there would because
you've got people around him now like
you mentioned, you know, Mariam Madison
and Steve Bannon and others, Alan
Dersowitz were saying, yes, there is a
possibility. There's an avenue for a
third term. There's an avenue for him to
not give up power. And they're trying to
create those conditions. And then the
question is, well, what the heck are
those conditions? Because only really
extreme situations would would that be
considered okay by the American people?
You have to create chaos in order for
that to happen. And it makes me wonder
now going backward to 2019 to the end of
2019 when CO first came around. Is was
that a plan of theirs? You know that
that and then they tried that and it
turned out a pandemic was not enough to
get us to stick with the same leader,
right? Uh we did still have an election.
We did still make that change. But uh so
if they tried like you say some sort of
an an emergency well they tried one of
the biggest emergencies of our lifetime
probably the biggest emergency of our
lifetime uh which is CO at this point.
So what would they try next? And I think
you might be right it would have to be I
think a civil war. I don't even think
war with Iran
>> would have would be enough because we've
been at war many times and we still
switch over president. So it would have
to be a civil war. Right.
>> It would have to be a civil war.
Exactly. And all the conditions are in
place now for a civil war. you have a
polarized information landscape where
people just live in their own bubbles.
So you look at the shooting in uh
Minnesota and both the left and right
are actually convinced they're right.
The the left is convinced that this is
an innocent woman who was killed for no
reason. The right is actually convinced
that she is is a a provocator. She went
in to resist authority. Um she did this.
She tried to run over the officer and
the officer did in defense. There's
actually no reconciliation between these
two sides. They all live in their own
social media bubbles.
>> But is that going to lead is that enough
historically? I mean, what has reeled
people to the point of picking up a gun
and shooting at their own family
members? Because that's what happens in
a civil war. Things have to get really
bad.
Look, the reality is that both the
Democrats and Republicans have um
certain paramil military factions that
will um incentivize and propel a civil
war. Okay. So, Republicans have these n
white nationalist groups uh the the
Proud Boys, the Democrats have um you
know, Antifa. So, these are street gangs
that they can deploy in order to achieve
certain political purposes. The reality
is that the oligarchy benefits from a
civil war uh because you have this
massive discontent and historically
either the people engage in a civil war
or they engage in revolution. So do you
do you prefer revolution or do you
prefer civil war? Um, also right now
what's happening in Washington is these
this massive conflict among deep among
certain deep state factions. And I I
don't people really appreciate the level
of conflict right now in Washington DC.
And traditionally, historically, the way
that these um conflicts among the elite
are settled is through civil war on the
streets. The people are sacrificed in
order to achieve certain political
agendas. And so, um, I think that what's
going to happen is that, um, over the
next few weeks, Trump is gonna is going
to continue to antagonize his opponents.
ICE is going to provoke the people.
You'll have random shootings of ICE
agents. Um, and then you have martial
law, National Guard, um, will come in
and these things can escalate really
quickly. And then you have these um
secret agents um um deep state agents
working among insurrection groups
organizing them uh encouraging violence
teaching them how to sabotage.
Um so um if you just look at movies like
Civil War and one battle after another
it's really predictive programming,
right? They're they're they're really
tra they're really trying to get people
in the mindset of civil war because
ultimately at the end of at the end of
the day civil war is what benefits the
oligarchy. One because it prevents
people from recognizing the true enemies
the oligarchy but also remember that
America is $30 trillion in debt. And so
if your house is worth a million dollars
and you owe $10 million to the bank,
what you do is you burn the house down
and you collect the insurance money. And
that's the that's the game plan of of
the of the oligarchy.
Okay. So, it sounds uh I mean this is
pretty scary. It sounds but it but it
makes sense. Uh we see it all the time
on the national nation against nation
level that elites will sit in their like
Oval Office or they'll sit, you know, in
their war rooms or their uh and they'll
sit there and they'll they'll throw
bodies at a war. They'll throw soldiers
at a war. um and they don't even think
twice about all of the the young men and
women who are going to be killed in
civilians, children who are going to be
killed in a war. And so you're saying
that like a soldier for the generals and
the elites, um the average citizen is
actually a soldier for the oligarchs.
They they view us as the same sort of
they just view us as soldiers and that
we're going to fight their battles for
them.
That is right. That is unfortunately
right.
>> So what are the factions
that you can sense that are fighting
behind the scenes?
>> Well, I mean the major faction is the
one that is establishment, right? The
establishment faction which has been in
power uh for the long for the longest
time um especially under Clinton and
Obama are um they're nationalists. Um
they're elite. they're they are um um
basically these coastal liberal elites
um or or what we can say as a deep state
and now you have the rise of mega first
and me first is supported by these
oligarchs like Peter Theo and Ellen Musk
and what they're trying to do is they're
trying to overthrow the deep state to
establish their own power and I would
say these are the two major factions and
then the left and right faction are this
or like the veneer of this deeper
conflict.
>> Yeah. So, it's a it's a deep state an an
old guard deep state being ousted by the
new guard deep state
>> that wants to take over. But there's
still going to be a deep state.
>> Yeah. Exactly. And the new deep state is
more like AI
>> and surveillance and they're bigger on
it seems that sort of Yeah.
>> Right. Exactly. So, Ogard is
Transnational Capital, Wall Street, and
then uh New Deep State is Palunteer,
Silicon Valley, these people.
>> Yeah. Right. Okay.
Oh, wow. Well, do we really want to be
fighting for them, I think, is what
every average person needs to um you
know, and this I I'm glad we're having
this conversation. It's going to make me
think twice about falling into the trap
of the culture wars. Although it's, you
know, it's not a
it's one of those things where it's um
it's going to be hard not to fall into
that trap because people are being
killed. I mean, that woman was killed
and that officer's life is also going to
be about about to be ruined. Well,
except I think you're right. Trump will
probably pardon Derek Schovin and then
probably pardon this this ICE officer as
well. So, this ICE officer, I don't
think really has to worry
Well, well, there won't be any trial for
this ICE officer. And what's going to
happen is that this ICE officer is going
to get invited to the White House and
he'll be a guest of honor for Trump and
this is this will just enrage half of
the population of America,
>> right? I mean,
>> I mean like like Trump is like Trump
used to work in reality TV, right? The
World Racing Federation. He knows how to
push buttons. He knows how to piss
people off so that they want to actually
take up arms.
>> Wow. Yeah. Okay. So, I mean, it's going
to be hard not to fall into the trap of,
you know, is it is this what happened or
is that what happened and and everybody
fighting with each other. Um, not just
with that, not with just that, but
they're they're turning a lot of things
into culture war issues that really
should not be culture war. Like for
example, Gaza, you know, that should not
that should just be a straightforward
thing that everybody watches and is
appalled by, but instead it's a culture
war thing. um you know if you're now
you're a crazy brain rot liberal if you
are against what Israel was doing and
their plan to take over you know that
that that region.
Thank you for watching this clip from
the full Kim Iverson show which you can
watch Monday through Friday 5:00 p.m.
Eastern, 2:00 p.m. Pacific at
kimsonshow.com.
See you there.